[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاده الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وبينما نتحدث ولا انت
تتفاعلوا احداث وتقع اخرى نبدا من باريس
وهذه الصور التي تصلنا من هناك وتشهد
العاصمه الفرنسيه ومدن فرنسيه اخرى
مظاهرات واحتجاجات مستمره على تعديل نظام
التقاعد
لوس انجلوس هي الاخرى تشهد اضرابا لالاف
من المعلمين الطواقم المساعده احتجاجا على
بنود في العقود المبرمه معهم
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد قمه هي الثانيه خلال عامين بوتين
ونظيره الصيني يعلنان من موسكو شراكه
الاستراتيجيه شامله
الرئيس الروسي يؤكد ان خطه السلام الصينيه
اساس لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا اذا كانت
كييف والغرب مستعدين لبحثها
وتم في تزويدها اي طرف في الحرب بالاسلحه
بعد تقارير عن خطه بريطانيه لدعم القوات
الاوكرانيه بذخائره من اليورانيوم والمنظم
بوتن يقول ان الخطوه دليل على نيه الغرب
محاربه روسيا بالفعل لا بالكلام ويتواعد
بالرد
واشنطن تفتتح اول قاعده عسكريه لها دائما
في بولندا وتعلن انها ستسلم دبابات الى
اوكرانيا في الخريف المقبل
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي يصدق على تعديل قانوني
يسمح للمستوطنين بالعيش في اربع مستوطنات
شمال الضفه الغربيه واشنطن تحذر من
التداعيات وتقول ان الكنيست نقض تعهدا
اسرائيليا للرئيس بوش قبل نحو 20 عاما
باخلاء البؤر الاستيطانيه غير الشرعيه
بالضفه والاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر من افشار
جهود التسويع
غداه وصفي بورن للاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه في تونس بالسيئه للغايه
وتحذييره من التداعيات على صعد عده وافضل
اوروبي في تونس لبحث ملفات عده ومناقشه
التعاون في قضيه الهجره الخارجيه التونسيه
تنتقد تصريحات المسؤول الاوروبي وتقول
انها مبالغ فيها وانتقائيه وسعيد يقول ان
بلاده لن تفرط في سيادتها
صعب يعرف
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا هذه التصريحات
المثيره المثيره للجدل لوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
عن عدم وجودي شعب فلسطيني واستخدامه ايضا
خريطه لاسرائيل تضم اراضيا فلسطينيه
والمملكه الاردنيه ردود الفعل تلاحق
الدوليه وعربيا واقليميا ترفض هذه
التصريحات وتحذر من دلالاتها والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما هي مالات
هذه التصريحات
وكيف يمكن ان تكون تداعياتها وجاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي حوالي 32
بالمئه يعتقدون ان تصريحات ستؤدي الى مزيد
من التوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بينما
ذهب 43% باتجاه تاجيل وتحريض ضد
الفلسطينيين واراء نحو 25% ان الاوضاع
تميل لمزيد من التوتر والتجاذبات داخل حك
ومه نتنياهو
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الكيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا كنا مع هذه الصور المباشره من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس احتجاجات جديده على قانون
التقاعد الذي اقر دون تصويت برلماني بل ان
الحكومه الفرنسيه نجت بصعوبه من تصويت
بسحب الثقه منها طبعا موضوع يتفاعل
وسنتفاعل مع هذا الموضوع حول تطوره في
الساعات المقبله
اختتمت اذا اليوم في موسكو قمه روسيه
صينيه هي الكبرى في تاريخ العلاقات بين
البلدين اختتمت بتوقيع عشر اتفاقيات تعاون
بين البلدين في مجالات مختلفه بالاضافه
الى وثيقتين بشان العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
الرئيس الروسي قال خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك
مع نظيره الصيني ان خطط السلام الصينيه
يمكن ان تكون اساسا لتسويه سلميه في
اوكرانيا بينما شدد الرئيس الصيني على
موقف بلاده المحايد من الازمه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تتوافق مع المنطق التاريخي لعلاقات
الشراكه بين بلدين يبنيان عالما متعدد
الاقطاب بهذا الوصف اختار الزعيم الصيني
تقييم زيارته الى موسكو ومباحثاته مع
نظيره الروسي
مباحثات توجت باتفاقيات تؤسس في راي
متابعينا لعلاقات استراتيجيه شامله ومتينه
بين البلدين
شي اكد على موقف بلاده المحايد من الازمه
في اوكرانيا والذي قال انه يستند الى
مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده
في الاشهر الماضيه قدمت الصين مبادره
لتسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا مبنيه على
اهداف ومبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده روسيا
والصين تتبنيان عالما متعدد الاقطاب
وعلاقتنا مهمه للعلم والانسانيه بوتين اكد
من جانبه على ان موسكو وبيجين بامكانهما
حل المشكلات الاكثر تعقيدا لكن الاولويه
في علاقتهما للاقتصاد والتجاره الرئيس
الروسي لم يستبعد ان تكون خطه السلام
الصينيه اساسا لتسويه سلميه في اوكرانيا
نقاط عده في خطه السلام الصينيه تتوافق مع
الموقف الروسي ويمكن ان تكون اساسا للحل
عندما تكون الدول الغربيه مستعدين لذلك
لكن حتى الان لا نرى اي استعداد منهم علمت
للتو ان بريطانيا اعلنت ماده كييف ليس فقط
بالدبابات بل بقذائف تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم البيان الختامي للقمه دعا الى تجنب
تدهور الازمه الاوكرانيه ووصولها الى
مرحله تخرج معها عن السيطره وان موسكو
وبيجين تطالبان النيتو بالالتزام بالطابع
الدفاعي واحترام سياده الدول مواقف قراء
فيها البعض تطابقا في نهج رافد للسياسات
الغربيه
سياسه الضغوط والعقوبات الغربيه بالروسيا
ومحاوله عزلها واضعاف اقتصادها منحت دفعه
لهذا التقارب الزعيم الصيني بعث برساله
صريحه على ان بلاده تدعم نهج بوتين لا
تمثل مخرجات القمه في راي متابعين تحديا
فقط لروسيا والصين في قدرتهما على تجاوز
الضغوط السياسيه والاقتصاديه والعسكريه
الغربيه فحسب بل تحديا لقدره الغرب ايضا
على مواجهه المستوى الذي وصل اليه التنسيق
بين موسكو وبجين في خضم
وضع الصين الى
الانتقاد نحو مستوى مختلف عما سبق فهل هو
اذا تحالف اضطراري مرحلي ام انه قطب دولي
منافس بدا يتشكل
امين الجزيره موسكو
هذا ويمثل تقارب الصيني الروسي مصدرا لقلق
غربي بسبب ما ينطوي عليه من اصطفاف مهدد
للنظام العالمي
وقيمه في الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان بحسب
الرؤيه الغربيه فوق هذه الرؤيه لم تكن
زياره الرئيس الصيني لموسكو الا شكلا من
اشكال الانحياز الى روسيا ودعم لرئيسها
بوتين المتهم بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
اوكرانيا انه صراع القوه على اشده سافرا
او مستخفيا تحت مقولات الى جيولوجيا كما
في تقرير فوزي بشرى
لست وحدك ربما كانت تلك هي رساله زياره
الرئيس الصيني
الى روسيا الى الرئيس بلاديمير بوتين
تحديدا وهو يخوض غمار حربه في اوكرانيا
الحرب التي لا يعرف احد كيف ولا متى
ستنتهي ولما ستاتي به من اصطفافات قد تضرب
بنيه النظام العالمي القائم او تخلخله
منذره بقيام اخر
وترقب الولايات المتحده ومن ورائها الغرب
الداعم لاوكرانيا بكثير من الحذر وربما
الخوف التقارب الصيني الروسي الذي سرعت
وثيرته الحرب فدفعت به الى افق
استراتيجيين هما تعبر عنه تصريحات
الرئيسيين الصيني والروسي فقد تعهد بتحقيق
تعاون شامل بين بلديهما على جميع
المستويات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه
والتكنولوجيه ومنبع الخشيه الغربيه من
العلاقه الاستراتيجيه بين الصين وروسيا هو
ان البلدين يمثلان موق رافضا للحيمره
الغربيه وقيمها وما يصفانه بطبيعتها
الامبرياليه وهما لا يترددان في الدعوه
الصريحه الى نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب
يضمن السلم والتعاون الدولي دونما اكراهات
الغرب من جهته لا سيما الولايات المتحده
ينظر الى البلدين خاصه الصين على انهما
خطران ماثلان بدرجات متفاوته مهددان
للنظام العالمي بقيمه الديمقراطيه هكذا
هما في التصور الاستراتيجي الامريكي
لمهددات الزعامه الامريكيه للعالمة وربما
لم يقصد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن احدا
اكثر من الصين وروسيا وهو يصدر وثيقه
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكي في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي بقوله
لن نترك مستقبلنا عرضه لاهواء اولئك الذين
لا يشاركوننا رؤيتنا لعالم حر ومنفتح
ومزدهر وامن عالم حر ومزدهر وامن هنا مقبل
الصراع بين رؤيتين تغريده السفير الامريكي
في طوكيو تلخص ذلك على افضل وجه وهو يعلق
على الزياره المفاجئه لرئيس الوزراء
الياباني
بانه مصطف مع الحريه اما
فمنحاز الى مجرم
وتوفر الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا لخطاب
الحرب الغربي مثالا على ما تصنعه السلطه
المستبده بقوتها من جرائم على غرار ما
يفعل بوتين في اوكرانيا او ما تفعل الصين
باقليتها المسلمه من الايغور وبسبب من هذه
الرؤيه التي ترد الدولتين الى اصل واحد في
الاستبداد تجاهل الغرب مبادره الرئيس
الصيني لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا والدخول في
مفاوضات فقد حذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
العالم من الانخداع بالمبادره الصينيه
وطعن في اهليه الصين المنحازه الى روسيا
في ان تكون وسيطا عادلا ومعروف ان الصين
امتنعت عن التصويت على مشروع قرار فرض
عقوبات على روسيا في مجلس الامن بل ان
الصينه تتهم بانها تزود موسكو بالاسلحه
رغم ان ذلك لم يثبت كما ان الغربه ياخذ
على الرئيس الصيني ما سماه بتفهمه للوضع
الروسي وهي اشاره خفيه في التصريحات
الى المخاطر التي رتبها التوسع حلف الناتو
شرقا الى الحدود الروسيه
واياما كانت الخلافات في طبيعه السلطه بين
الغرب من جهه والصين وروسيا من جهه اخرى
فانما لم يعد خافيا هو ان مستقبل التقارب
الاستراتيجي بين الصين وروسيا سيكون محددا
اساسيا للتغيرات الجيوسياسيه التي قد
تشهدها العشريه الاولى من هذا القرن
فالصين وفق المراقبين لن تسبح بهزيمه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا مطوره
موقفها بحسب مجريات الحرب لان الهزيمه
العسكريه قد تؤدي الى انهيار نظام بوتين
بالكليه في موسكو وساعدها قد تجد الصين
نفسها الهدف الثاني في استراتيجيه الغرب
وخاصه امريكا لتصفيه او تحيد المنافسين
على قياده العالم
وكل ذلك قد يجعل في راي المراقبين التحالف
الصيني الروسيه تحالف ضروره استراتيجيه
تحثمها غريزه البقاء في عالم لم يغادر
يوما منطقه الغابه
الباحثه الاولى في المركز الاوروبي
التابعه للمجلس الاطلسي ومن موسكو وسفير
اندريبا كلانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه
الدبلوماسيين الروس وابدا بضيفه من واشنطن
مفردات كثيره استخدمت في القمه الروسيه
الصينيه الثانيه خلال عامين عشر اتفاقيات
شراكه استراتيجيه شامله وليست مجرد شراكه
استراتيجيه حقبه جديده
البلدان يبنيان معا
عالما متعدد الاقطاب
هذا هو الذي قيل ما الذي سيحدث
في قولكم عن كثير من هذه الامور بوتن حتى
قال انه رحب بزياره صديقه الحميم الى
موسكو لكن اذا ما تعمقنا قليلا سنجا ان
هذا زواج مصلحه وليس زواج عن حب لان كلا
الطرفين سيجدوا ما ينفعه لدى الطرف الاخر
الصين مثلا وعدت في التعاون مع روسيا فيما
يتعلق بالتكنولوجيا بوتين وروسيا يعطونا
مثلا الصين فرص للحلول محلي الشركات
الغربيه التي غادرت روسيا بعد غزو
اوكرانيا ايضا فيما يتعلقوا بخطوط
المواصلات الى الشرق الاقصى لكن حقيقه
انهما قال ان هذا ليس تحالفا يعطي بعض
التغطيه لم في رايه نعم وهذه نقطه في غايه
الاهميه اذهب بها الى ضيفي من موسكو
يعني كلمه تحالف لم تذكر ذكرت كلمات كثيره
لكن تحالف لم تذكر كما تقول ضيفاتنا ما
شكل هذه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله كيف
ستكون
اريد ان اقول ان ليس لدى موسكو
عذرا اريد ان اقول ان لم يكن هناك اهتمام
بمثل هذه الليرات من قبل منذ 60 عام والان
نحن نشعر بنفس الاهتمام اتجاه القياده
الصينيه ما حدث في موسكو تحديدا ان موقف
موسكو يعتمد على ان ما حدث هو حدث مهم جدا
من وجهه النظر الجيو السياسيه في العلاقات
بين الصين وروسيا الحديث عن ان موسكو لاول
مره اتفقت على انك نموذج العالم سوف يتغير
وليس في اتجاه
تشكيل مختلف المراكز المسيطره بل هو شيء
اخر سوف يشكل مركزا لا يقع في الغرب بل
يقع في الشرق هذا يعني ان الغرب والشرق في
المستقبل سوف يتغير تماما حتى الجذ
المجالس الاستشاريه سوف تتمركز في الشرق
بين روسيا
والصين نحن ناخذ على عاتقنا المهام
الدبلوماسيه
ونحارب
الاستعماريه الغربيه ونعتقد اننا سوف نكون
قيادات
لما يسموه في الصين الاغلبيه في الارض هذا
يعني اننا سبع مليارات على الارض نعتقد ان
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط كل هذه الدول سوف
تدعمنا علما انه سوف يكون هناك
مقاومه صعبه في المستقبل لذلك مع كل اهميه
النزاع في اوكرانيا بالرغم من هذا هذا
الموضوع لم يكون الموضوع على اهم في موسكو
كان هناك الاهداف الجيوب السياسيه هي
الاهم
اعود الى
يعني انت قلت انه ليس تحالفا لكن هل هل
ترك الغرب اي فرصه
لهذين العملاق العملاقين الاقتصاديه
والعسكري الروسي والصيني سوى التحالف اليس
اليس اليست البنيه التحتيه للنيتو على
حدود روسيا وتتجه ايضا شرقا في اسيا الى
الصين كما يقول الصينيون هل امام هذين
العملاقين الاقتصادي والسياسي والعسكري
سوى التحالف
اعتقد اننا يجب ان نكون واضحين هناك عملاق
واحد في هذا السيناريو وهو الصين
وروسيا واضحا انهما الشريك الاصغر في هذه
العلاقه واذا ما القينا نظره على الوثيقه
الاستراتيجيه التي تم توقيعها
والنقاشات التي دارت والاتفاقات التي
ابرمت تدلل على ذلك
في النهايه روسيا مقطوعه تقريبا عن النظام
الدولي منذ ان بدات غزها لاوكرانيا اذا
نعتقد ان ازاء وضع يجعل من الصين روسيا
تنظران الى بعضهما البعض
كشريكين يتصديان للنظام الدولي الذي
تقودها امريكا والغرب لكن يجب ان نعي ان
هناك حدودا لهذه العلاقه والشراكه رغم
انهم يقولون شراكه مفتوحه النهايه لا
اعتقد ان الشيء يريد ان يجد نفسه في موقف
يكون فيه حليفا لفوت ثم يفقد مكانته
الدوليه
مكانته وقوته تاتي من قدره الصين على
صياغه الاوضاع في العالم اذا دعونا نراقب
هذه الاوضاع عن كثب وكان لافتا سيد
بكلانوب حرص الرئيس الصيني على تاكيد حياد
الصين في المساله الاوكرانيه يعني الحلفاء
ليس بينهم حياه اذا كانت الصين ترى ان
روسيا على حق فيما يجري في اوكرانيا فكيف
يمكن ان تكون محايده
لم يكن حقيقيا من اين جئت بهذا لم يقول
هذا الرئيس الصيني في موسكو على العكس قال
بكل تاكيد ان الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه سوف تصبح اقوى واقوى مع
السنوات القادمه وهذا ما اعلنه رؤساء
الوزراء ايضا ولقد عملوا كثيرا على
تغييرات جذريه في الخطط للسنوات القادمه
للتغييرات والتطويرات في العلاقات في
التعاون الاستراتيجي والعسكري وفي التعاون
في مجال الطاقه وايضا في التعاون في مجال
التكنولوجيا والتكنولوجيا العسكريه ونحن
نصل الى مستوى من التعاون ممكن ان يسمح
لنا بتحقيق جميع الاهداف التي اعلنت وهي
ان نصبح الدول الاساسيه التي
تحدد خط تطور النظام الدولي
والتضييق على النظام الغربي الذي يؤدي الى
كارثه عالميا
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكن الرئيس الصيني اكد من
موسكو حياد الصين فيما يتعلق بالازمه
الاوكرانيه وقال انه يستند على مبادئ
ميثاق الامم المتحده شكرا انجيبك نائب
رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس واشكر
ضيفتنا من واشنطن
الباحثه الاولى في المركز الاوروبي
التابعه للمجلس الاطلسيين
[موسيقى]
هجم الرئيس الروسي لدمير بوتين تصريحاتي
بريطانيا بشان امداد كييف بقذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم قال انها دليل علانيه
الغرب محاربه روسيا فعلا لا قولا اتوعد
خلال مباحثات مع نظير الصيني في موسكو بان
روسيا سترد بشكل مناسب على الخطوه
البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
من احتمال توريد لندن اسلحه تحتوي على
يورانيوم منظم الى اوكرانيا قال ان الامر
سينتهي بشكل سيء للغايه بالنسبه لبريطانيا
وبدورها قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخارفا ان خطط
بريطانيا لنقل قضائف اليورانيوم المنظم
الى اوكرانيا اشبهوا بالسيناريو اليوزلفي
وكانت نائب نائبه وزير الدفاع البريطاني
انابيل جولدي قالت في وقت سابق لذخائر
خارقه للدروع من اليورانيوم المنظم سترسل
مع دبابات تشالنجر 2 البريطانيه الى
المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه
والضابط السابق في المخابرات العسكريه
البريطانيه امانه من موسكو اليكساندر
الخبير العسكري والمختص في شؤون النيت
وابدا بضيفي من موسكو تحذير الرئيس الروسي
من استخدام مواد نوويه او اسلحه تحتوي على
مواد نوويه
هل هل اليورانيوم والمنظم يدخل ضمن هذا
التصنيف
المنظم الذي يريدون ان يستخدموه في
الدبابات شيلنجر هو خطير لانه ينشر
الغبار الملوث في المناطق حيث تستخدم هذه
الذخيره خاصه ان هذه الذخيره هي لديها
قدرات مضاده للمدرعات قويه جدا لان الحديث
عن
اليورانيوم المنظم الذي يذوب التيتانيوم
وهو ممكن ان يذيب متر كامل من المعدن عدا
عن ذلك هو يصبح حاد جدا عندما يتعرض
للحراره او للذوبان عندما استخدم في
السابق كان درجه انتشار امراض السرطان زاد
الى سته مرات وهذه المعلومات
مثبته في
صربيا حيث استخدمت هذه الذخيره طيب كيف
سيكون الرد
سوجا
على رده الفعل التي رايتها من طرف
السياسيين والمسؤولين الروس روسيا تعتبر
استخدام هذه الذخيره
كاستخدام القنبله القذره تماما لذلك هذا
سوف يجعلنا نرد بطريقه مناسبه هذا يعني ان
روسيا
وموسكو سوف تعتقد ان نحن نعتبر ان دانسك
هي اراضي روسيه سوف نعطي باستخدام هذه
الذخيره استخداما للقنابل القذره على
اراضي روسيه والرد سوف يكون قاسي جدا قد
يصل الى استخدام الرؤوس
النوويه لان استخدام اليورانيوم المردد
يعني استخداما للاسلحه الاسلحه الدمار
الشامل هل هذه وجهه النظر البريطانيه ايضا
اسال الدكتور
فرانك المحاضر في اوكسفورد هل هل هذه
يعتبر ادخالا لمواد نوويه الى الحرب
طبعا
بالتاكيد هو
هذا يعني ان روسيا ستسحب
الذخائر والروس الحربيه من دباباتها التي
تستخدمها منذ فتره وهي تشبه هذه الذخيره
اما فيما يتعلق بان هذه اسلحه نوويه
فهذا طبعا مليء بالافتراضات ويكادو يصلوا
درجه الهراء هذه قذائف فعاله جدا مضاده
للدبابات وسوف تكسر حمايه الدبابات
الروسيه هذا هو الغرض منها مثل قضاف
سيناكس واحد واثنين الروسيه مصممه لخرق
دروع الدبابات الاوكرانيه في العراق وفي
بلدان اخرى وجهت اتهامات مشابهه
وهذه قضاء نعم مثيره للقلق لكن وفقا
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه التي اثرت تقريرا في ديار في يناير
الصيد لابد ان يعرف ذلك في قالت ان
الطواقم الدبابات التي تعرضت لهذه القذائف
لم لم يبدو ما حدث صحيحا اما ما قوله عن
دونيس كونها اراضي روسيه هي ليست كذلك هي
اراضي اوكرانيه احتلتها روسيا
بشيء مناقض لكل القوانين اما الحديث عن اي
قضايا انسانيه فهذا امر حقيقه غير مقبول
من جيش قتل اكثر من النصف مليون الصيده
الثامنه في ارضك هذه الامور جيدا ولماذا
ولماذا تلجا بريطانيا لهذا التصعيد
باستخدام قذائف على الاقل هنالك انت قلت
انها مثيره للقلق هذه القذائف مثيره للقلق
يمكن ان تؤدي الى اصابات بالسرطان لماذا
يدخل هذا العنصر الى المعركه اصلا
بقول انه كانت هناك تقارير مقلقه لكن
مؤخرا وجد ان هناك متغيرات كثيره لم توصل
الى هذه الاستنتاجات انا شخصيا اعتقد ان
قادتنا السياسيين كان يجب ان يتحلوا بحيطه
وحذر اكثر
وحصافه اكثر لكن نحن نتحدث في النهايه عن
دبابه والتي قد لا تصل للميدان قبل شهرين
روسيا تنشر
2500 دبابه تستخدم ذخيره مشابهه لاكثر من
عام الان اليس من المبالغه السيد
ارتامونوف ان تقول
ان روسيا سترد باستخدام رؤوس نوويه على
اربعه عشره دبابه يمكن ان تستخدم قذائف
يورانيوم منظف اليس هذا فعل رد فعل مبالغا
فيه
بطريقه التاليه هناك
اسلحه تكتيكيه مختلفه وذخيره تكتيكيه
مختلفه بما فيها الذخيره
التكتيكيه التي تضرب الدبابات
والاهداف
المحدده لذلك هذا ليست رده رده فعل غير
عادله ولكن اسمح لي بالرد على الضيف من
بريطانيا انه ليس هناك اي مقبره
دفن فيها الاف من المدنيين الذين قتلوا من
قبل الجيش الروسي الجيش الروسي لا يقتل
الالاف من المدنيين نشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
موسكو الكسندر
الخبير العسكري والمختص في الشؤون النيتو
من اوكسفورد نشكر فرانك
المحاضر في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه بجامعه
بورسموس والضابط السابق في المخابرات
العسكريه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
قال نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
فيدان واشنطن منزعجه من تمرير الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي تشريعا يلغي بنودا من قانون فك
الارتباط مع قطاع غزه ومستوطنات شمال
الضفه الغربيه وصف باتيلا قرار الكنيست
بالاستفزازيه مضيفا انه ياتي بنتائج عكسيه
لجهود احلال الهدوء وقال انه يمثل نقدا
لتعهداتنا اعلنتها تل ابيب لاداره بوشلاب
قبل نحو 20 عاما
الولايات المتحده منزعجه جدا من تمرير
الكنيست الاسرائيلي تشريعا يلغي اجزاء
هامه من قانون فك الارتباط الصادر عام
2005 بما يشمل الاجزاء المتعلقه بمنع
اقامه مستوطنه شمال الضفه الغربيه تلك
الخطوه تمثل نقدا واضحا لتعهدات اسرائيل
واشنطن اذ اكد رئيس الوزراء الراحل اريال
شارون كتابيا نيابه عن اسرائيل قبل نحو 20
عاما للرئيس جورج بوش الابن بانه ملتزم
باخلاء المستوطنات والبؤر في شمال الضفه
الغربيه لاحلال الاستقرار والحد من
الاحتكاك
وكان الكنيسه الاسرائيلي قد صدق على الغاء
بنود في قانون فك الارتباط عن غزه واربعه
مستوطنات شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله بعد
18 عاما على اقراره ويرمي التعديل الى فتح
الاستيطان مجددا في هذه المناطق
الفلسطينيه بالضفه والقطاع واثارت الخطوه
الاسرائيليه ردود فعل فلسطينيه واوروبيه
مستنكره
ابتهاج وغبطه لم يخفيها المستوطنون الذين
اقاموا حلقات الرقص في باحات الكنيست على
غير المالوف والمسموح به
كان ذلك تعبيرا عن تصحيح غبن تاريخي من
وجهه نظرهم في وقت كان الكنيست يصدق فيه
على الغاء قانون الانفصال الذي اقر قبل 18
عاما وهو ما يفسخ المجال امام اعاده توطين
اربع مستوطنات تم اخلائها شمال الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
لقد صدقنا على الغاء قانون الانفصال هؤلاء
الناس الرائعون سيعودون لارضهم والى ارض
عائلاتهم ولن يعدوا بعد الان مخالفين
للقانون نتطلع لاعاده بناء المستوطنات
وهذا سيساعدنا ليس في الاستيطان فحسب انما
في محاربتنا للارهاب وتطوير ارض اسرائيل
بذلك يوفي بن يمين التنياهو باحد الشروط
احزاب اليمين المتطرف للانضمام الى
توليفته فمرات عده حاول المستوطنون اعاده
توطين المستوطنات الاربعه واقاموا في
مستوطنه حومش كنيسا تحول الى بؤره غير
قانونيه لكن محاولاتهم السابقه اصطدمت
برفض سياسي داخلي تاره وبضغوط دوليه تاره
اخرى ويعتبر الفلسطينيون هذه الخطوه
تقويضا لحل الدولتين ومنسجمه مع رؤى اعضاء
حكومه اليمين التي تنفي وجود الشعب
الفلسطيني هذا القرار يهدف الى تقويض حل
الدولتين
وهذا ليس جديدا على دعاه المحو والحرق
والاباده الجماعيه وعدم الاعتراف بوجود
شعب فلسطيني على هذه الارض في عام 2005
اقر الكنيست قانون الانفصال احادي الجانب
وبموجبه اخلط اسرائيل احدى وعشرين مست في
قطاع غزه قبل ان ينسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي
الى خط الهدنه اما في الضفه الغربيه فاخلت
اسرائيل 4 مستوطنات لكنها اخضعتها
لاجراءات امنيه ورفضت اعاده السيطره عليها
الى السلطه الفلسطينيه هي خطوه يرد
بنيامين تنياهو من خلالها العرفان لاحزاب
اقصى اليمين التي تشكل عماد استقرار
حكومته السادسه لكنها خطوه في توقيتها
تبدو في نظر الفلسطينيين كمن يصب الزيت
على النار المشتعله في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله ليسكر راما الجزيره القدس الغربيه
وايضا
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه سيد كراولي
الخارجيه الامريكيه ابدت انزعاجا من هذه
الخطوه من الكنيست الاسرائيلي ما الذي
يزعجها
وكما تعلمون لدينا اجتماع مهم في شرم
الشيخ خلال فتره نهايه الاسبوع حيث
الطرفان باتخاذ خطوات ملموسه لتخفيف
التوتر ولكن بعد ساعات فقط ذلك صدر هذا
القرار من قبل الكنيسه الاسرائيلي وفي
الواقع هذا يزيد التوترات في الضفه
الغربيه وبالتالي فهذا مثال على
القيام بخطوه الى الامام ثم خطوه الى
الوراء وهو هذا هو ما يحصل مع الاسف عندما
يتعلق الامر بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه وما الذي يزعج الخارجيه
الامريكيه والاداره الامريكيه في زياره
التوتر في الضفه الغربيه
ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه قالت في شرم الشيخ
بانها ستحد
وتقللوا سياسات الاستوطنات العلاقه سته
اشهر كما تذكر ولكن ما نجده ان الكنيسه
اعطى موافقه
للمستوطنين ان يعودوا الى اربعه مواقع
كانت قد بنيت منذ فتره طويله ثم تركت منذ
فتره طويله وهذا مثال جيد على عمليه
التوازن الذي تشتهر فيه حكومات نتنياهو
تستطيع نقول الولايات المتحده نحن لا
نتحدث عن مستوطنات جديده ولكن ترفع تشجع
الداعمين المتطرفين لها بالموافقه على
اعادتهم الى هذه المستوطنات وهذا السبب مع
الاسف هذا هو الوضع الحالي ومن غير محتمل
ان نرى اي اجراءات جاده من اي من الجانبين
وبالتالي هذا طبعا شيء مزعج للولايات
المتحده
والدول الاخرى التي تشجع الحوار المستمر
الذي شاهدناه قبل فتره في شرم الشيخ نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا السفير بي جي كراولي المتحدث
السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
بعد قليل في فقره المتابعه مسلط الضوء على
وجودي اول قاعده عسكريه امريكيه في وارسو
تشرف على قوات واشنطن البريه في اوروبا
والنيت يقول انها انه حرك اكبر عدد من
القوات في تاريخ الحلف منذ بدء الحرب على
اوكرانيا لحمايه مصالح اعضائح
[موسيقى]
على وقع تراشق سياسي بين الجانبين وصل وفد
من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى تونس لبحث الوضع
السياسي في تونس هو يبحث ايضا ملف الهجره
وقد وصفت الخارجيه التونسيه تصريحات مفوض
الشؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوست
بورل حول الخوف من انهيار الوضع في تونس
بغير المتناسبه وقالت الخارجيه التونسيه
في بيان ان التصريحات مبالغ فيها في ضوء
ما وصفوه بصمود الشعب التونسيه عبر تاريخه
وايضا فيما يتعلق بملف الهجره الى اوروبا
وفي المقابل رحبت الخارجيه التونسيه
بمعتبرته دعما بناء من قبل العديد من
الشركاء بما في ذلك ايطاليا مشيره الى ان
تونس ستبقى منفتحه على ما وصفتها بالشراكه
المسؤوله
ومن جهه الفريق القرن المتحدث باسم
الاتحاد الاوروبي لويس ميغيل وينو للجزيره
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحترم السياده تونس
باعتبارها دوله مستقله ذات السياده لافتا
لانه هناك اتفاقيه شراكه بين الطرفين
مبنيه على التزامات من بينها ملف حقوق
الانسان والديمقراطيه
نحن نحترم سياده تونس يعني بس نحدد تونس
دوله ذات السياده مستقله نحن نقول فقط بان
لدينا اتفاقيه بيننا
طرفين التزامات في مجال حقوق الانسان هل
اتفاقيه مبنيه على مبادئ وكيا مشتركه اللي
هي يعني احتراق الانسان
هذه الثوره التونسيه نحن نحترم كثيرا هذا
الامور وعلينا مره اخرى خبره لنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وممكن يعني نحن نقول فقط
باننا نقدم هذه الخبره السلطات التونسيه
الذين تضامنوا كبيرا حكومه وشعبا باتجاه
تونس ونحن مستعدون للمزيد
قال المرشد الايراني علي خامني الغربه
فشله في عزل بلاده مضيفنا من الطيران عززت
علاقاتها مع دول المنطقه واسيا وافريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه اكد المرشد الايراني في
كلمه الله بمدينه مشهد استعداد ايران
للتعاون مع اوروبا شريطه عدم اتباعها
سياسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل
اعمى حسب تعبيره
العرب سعى الى عزل ايران لكن ما حدث عكس
ذلك فقد فشل في سياساته علاقتنا بالغرب
الضعيفه لكنها قويه مع عدد كبير من دول
اسيا وحصلنا على عضيه تجمعات اقليميه مهمه
وتعززت علاقاتنا مع الدول المنطقه ومع
شعوبها وكذلك عززنا علاقتنا مع افريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه لسنا غاضبين من اوروبا
فنحن مستعدون للتعاون معها اذا لم تتبع
سياسه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بشكل
اعمى ولا يمكننا الثقه بالغرب وعلينا
الاعتماد على قدراتنا الداخليه مهم
الى سويسرا وطلبت نقابات بتجميد تسريح بعض
موظفي مصرف كريدي سويس حتى نهايه العام
الجاري وتاتي هذه المطالب بعد استحواذ
مصرفيوبياس على مصرف كريدي سويس في خطوه
حظيت بموافقه ودعم الحكومه السويسريه
تفاديا الانهيار النظام المص رفي في
البلاد
مختار زاده مواطن سويسري استثمر في
السندات بمصرف كريدي سويس يشعر بالاحباط
بعد ان ابلغه موظف في البنك ان قيمه
سنداته قد انخفضت
ما حدث مؤسف للغايه مصرف
مقابل كسره خبز فقط الاملاك العقاريه
الكريدي سويست تفوق قيمه هذه المقايضه
الماليه وهذا خفض من قيمه اسهمنا انها
صفقه القرن ليوبيس لتفادي مثل هذه
الانتكاسات يحاول بنك يو بي اس الذي
استحوذ على مصرف كريدي سويس ترميمه صوره
القطاع المصرفي السويسري معتمدا على اكثر
من 9 مليارات يورو تعهدت الحكومه
السويسريه بتوفيرها لتحمل الخسائر
المحتمله جراء عمليه الاستحواذ تحرك اسهم
مؤقتا في تهدئه الاسواق لكنه لم يفلح في
الاجابه عن سيل الاسئله التي تواجه القطاع
المصرفي السويسري لكونومي
وسينخفض حجم القطاع المصرفي ولن تعود
معجزه المصارف السويسريه الى ما كانت عليه
من قبل مساهمه البنوك السويسريه في الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي ستنخفض
استشراف يضاف الى التوقعات القادمه التي
تلقي بظلالها على موظفي كريدي سويس فالملك
الجديد اخبرهم بانهم سيواجهون اياما
واسابيع عصيبه وهو ما اعتبرته النقابات
تمهيدا لحمله تسريح جماعي قد تطول وفق بعض
التوقعات اكثر من عشره الاف موظف سمعه
البنوك السويسريه على المحك تلك قراءه لا
تغيب عن تقييم
معظم المحللين الاقتصاديين الذين يستشرفون
تراجع ثقه المستثمرين بالقطاع المصرفي
السويسري بعد ازمه كريدي سويس ايمن زبير
الجزيره جنيف
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
العقيد باترويد ان البنتاجون يخطط لتسليم
اوكرانيا 31 دبابه
خلال الخريف المقبل من العام الجاري في
موعد اقرب مما كان مقررا سابقا
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه وبتنسيق الوثيق مع
كيف اتخذت القرار بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ما سيمكننا من تسريع المده الزمنيه
للتسليم بشكل كبير وتقديم هذه القدرات
المهمه الى اوكرانيا بحلول خريف العام
الجاري
واشار المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه العقيد باتشر لان القوات
الامريكيه تواصل عملياتها فوق البحر
الاسود والتحليق في الاجواء الدوليه بما
يراعي ويتفق والقانون الدولي
ه
فيما يتعلق بعمليتنا فوق البحر الاسود
نواصل القيام بها والتحليق في المجال
الجوي الدولي مما يتوافق مع القانون
الدولي حيثما يسمح لنا بذلك لكنني ولاسباب
امنيه تشغيليه لن اذكر التفاصيل المتعلقه
بالمسارات والمهام والجداول الزمنيه
واشياء من هذا القبيل الا اننا مستمرون في
القيام بتلك العمليات
وكما جاء في صدر الحصاد الولايات المتحده
افتتحت قاعده عسكريه في بولندا القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه في اوروبا تتعدد منذ
الحرب البارده وتوسعت شرقا اكثر ضمن
انتشار الاكبر لحل في شمال الاطلسي وتوجد
اغلب القواعد الامريكيه في اوروبا على
الاراضي الالمانيه وكان هدفه تلك القوات
الاساسيه هو ردع الاتحاد السوفيتي عن
التوغل داخل
اوروبا الغربيه وكذا الرقم الاكبر للقوات
الامريكيه على الاراضي الاوروبيه خلال
ذروه الحرب البارده في الخمسينيات
والستينيات من القرن الماضي هو 400 الف
عسكري امريكي اكثر من نصف هؤلاء يوجد في
المانيا الباقي موجود في دول اوروبا
الغربيه الاخرى الاعضاء في حلف الشمال
الاطلسي اضافه الى تركيا
اشهرها قاعده رامشتاين الجويه التي تاسست
في عام
1953 واختيرت لتكون مقر المركز الفضائي
لحلف الشمال طبعا هي في المانيا اضافه الى
قواعد في مناطق اخرى بالمانيا
كاشتوتغار وانسباخ توجد ايضا قاعده
امريكيه في بينرس ببلجيكا وتاسست عام 2005
اذا هذا عن القواعد الامريكيه الموجوده في
اوروبا لكن الانظار تتجه الان وفي سياق
اقليمي معقد بسبب حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا
تتجه الى بولندا التي فتحت فيها افتتحت
فيها اول قاعده عسكريه امريكيه دائمه على
التراب البولندي وتحديدا في مدينه بوزان
التي تقع غرب البلاد واستنادا لورسو انشات
القاعده بناء على قرار الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن لعام 2022 بغيه دعم البنيه التحتيه
للقوات الامريكيه المتمركزه في هولندا
وقياده واداره المواقع المتقدمه للقوات
الامريكيه فيها
وزاره الدفاع الكولانديه قالت ان مهمه
القاعده الرئيسيه هي التنسيق والاشراف على
القوات البريه الامريكيه في اوروبا وتنسيق
التعاون بين القوات الامريكيه وحلف الشمال
الاطلسي شدت الوزاره على اهميتها من اجل
امن بولندا وامن الجناح الشرقي للنيتو
باكمله وتعتبر القاعده الامريكيه في
بولندا ثامنه قاعده للقوات الامريكيه في
اوروبا يوجد حاليا نحو 10,000 جندي امريكي
في هولندا
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع يضم الينا من بروكسيل
نيكولاس المسؤول في حلف شمال الاطلسي
سابقا سيد ويليامز ما الذي ستحققه هذه
القاعده في بولندا بالنسبه لمجهودات
الولايات المتحده في المواجهه مع روسيا
وايضا حلف الشمال الاطلسي
ان هذا هذا العمليه هي جزء من شبكه
متكامله من القوات العسكريه والمقرات
العسكريه
التي تضعها وضعتها
حلف الناتو منذ غزوه شوفها جزيره القرن في
2014 وبالتالي فهذه القاعده ينبغي النظر
اليها
على انها
على انه واحد من ثمان قواعد امريكيه كما
قلتم انتم ولكن ضمن الشبكه متكامله من
المقرات لتمكين
اعاده تعزيز
تعزيز قوه
بولندا ودول البلطيق رومانيا وبلغاريا في
حاله حصول هجوم عليها او اي غزو تقوم به
روسيا والي بدا يعتبر هذا السيناريو
واقعيا ان تقوم روسيا بغزو دول اخرى بخلاف
اوكرانيا
الصعب ان نقول واقعيه هذا السيناريو ولكن
نستطيع ان نقول ان هذه الدول دول لديها
مخاوف وخش مخاوف حقيقيه
ومنذ غزوه شبه جزيره القرم
وثمن الغاز الذي قاموا به 2022 لم تعد اي
دوله في اوروبا الغربيه ان تخاطره
يتعلق بمنظوماتها الدفاعيه
وذلك
منعها او الرد على روسيا من قيام باي شيء
اخر لتعريض امنهم للخطر واستقرار بلادهم
للخطر ولهذا السبب فان الولايات المتحده
تعزز وجودها بطلب من بولندا ودول الاخرى
وخاصه دول البلطيق مثلا يعني هل هذا
هذا الوجود العسكري الامريكي ليس له ثمن
اوروبي
نعم نعم
الثمن غالي وكبير جدا فلو تركنا جانبا
التزويد اوكرانيا بس اسلحه
في عام 2022
امريكا انفقت 3.8 مليار دولار على هذه
الشبكه
من القواعد العسكريه
والمعدات وتدوير الافراد والقوات هذه سنه
طلبوا
4.2 مليار دولار اضافه الى
الى
النفقاتهم الاعتياديه الاخرى وبالتالي هذا
الامر يكلف ولايه المتحده اموالا طائله
ولا يكلف اوروبا
طبعا طبعا يكلف الاوروبيين ايضا ايضا
مبالغ باهظه وعاليه
لذلك يشجع بل يصر على ان نفقات الدفاعيه
تزداد
لان امريكا لن تقدم دعما للاوروبين للابد
نعم هذه هذه حاله طارئه قصيره المدى او
متوسط المدى نظرا لغزوه اوكرانيا لكن
الولايات المتحده توقع ان اوروبا او
الاوروبيين سيدافعون انفسهم بلا حد كبير
امريكا ستساعدهم لكنها لن تصفع العبء عن
الاوروبيين وهذا على المدى الفوري وعلى
المدى البعيد هل تظن ان هذه القواعد هنالك
100 الف جندي امريكا الان في اوروبا بحسب
بعض التقديرات
هل هل هذه هل هذا يوصل الرساله الكافيه
تظن ان هذا الوجود يمكن ان يرضعها عن اي
شيء
هذا هذه مساله دوره نفسيه نعم هي رساله
قويه جدا موجهه الى روسيا
وان الناتو مع الولايات المتحده
يقعون على حدودهم
ولكن
انك ما تعتبره
ذاته هو ردع لروسيا تراه روسيا على انه
انه عمليه هجوميه عدائيه ضد روسيا ولسوء
الحظ هل هذه الدوره النفسيه نظرا لتاريخ
اوروبا
صعب او تجعل المستحيل كسرها هذه الدوره
وبالتالي فهذا الامر او هذا الوضع خطير
جدا وانا في رايي ان الامر سيزداد سوءا
من بروكسل المسؤول السابق في حلف الشمال
الى شكرا جزيلا لك
هذا نصل مشاهدينا الى نهايه حصاد الليله
تصبحون على خير في امان الله
[موسيقى]